- La journée du 6 décembre
se déroule toujours à peu près
de la même façon à l'École
polytechnique de Montréal,
depuis 33 ans.
Même si les étudiants
d'aujourd'hui n'ont aucun
souvenir de la tragédie
qui a secoué leur école
et tout le pays ce jour-là, en
1989, la mrerere des 14 jeunes
femmes assassinées s'impose.
JEANNE MARCHAND, étudiante en
génie chimique, prés. de Poly-FI
- On se remet un peu dans
l'état d'esprit de comment ça
s'est passé il y a 33 ans,
et c'est quelque chose
qui nous affecte.
Ça s'est passé dans
nos corridors, dans nos classes.
MARJORIE D'ASTOUS-LEPAGE,
étudiante en génie mécanique
- Il y a encore féféféminicides,
il y a encore des actes
de violence, il y a encore
des crimes qui sont commis
avec armes à feux.
- C'est un devoir émémémoire,
puis ça n'a pas juste touché
la communauté de Poly.
Ça a touché la collectivité,
même le Québec en entier
s'en rappelle. Fait que c'
un moment pour penser aux
victimes, penser aux familles.
Il y a un gros mix d'émotions
aujourd'hui, c'est très chargé
comme journée.
- Sophia Roy fait un doctorat
en génie chimique, marchant
ainsi dans les traces de sa mère
arrivée à Polytechnique deux ans
après le féminicide de 1989,
qui a été un choc pour elle,
un réveil brutal.
NATHALIE SIRORIS, ancienne
étudiante en génie industriel,
- Ça m'a dit : Il va falloir
que je sois forte pour aller
dans cette profession-là.
C'est plus ça que je me suis
dit, en tant que jeune fille.
Mais j'étais convaincue,
c'est ça que je voulais faire,
puis j'adorais les sciences.
- Mademoiselle Sophia Roy.
(applaudissements)
- L'étudiante reçoit une bourse
de 30 000 dollars de l'Ordre
de la rose blanche, créée
en l'honneur des victimes
de la tuerie de Polytechnique.
- Ma vision du futur est
celle d'une société complètement
redessinée pour pallier
les défis imposés par
la crise climatique.
- Sophia a choisi le géniepour s
au réchauffement de la planète.
Mais avec encore seulement 15 %
de femmes au sein de l'Ordre
des ingénieurs du Québec,
elle sait qu'elle va
affronter des vents de face,
comme sa mère l'a fait.
- Dans l'industrie, il y a
encore des échos que les femmes
en position de leadership
se font moins écouter.
T'sais, c'est comme un peu
difficile. Il y a des biais
inconscients aussi qui restent.
- Oui, il y a des biais,
conscients ou inconscients.
Mais je trouve que depuis
30 ans, il y a beaucoup
de chemin qui a été parcouru.
Mais c'est certain qu'on a
encore un petit peu de chemin
à faire.
♪ (piano) ♪
- À 17 h 10, 14 jets de lumière
illuminent, un à un, le ciel de
Montréal, à l'heure précise
où Marc Lépine avait commencé
à tirer sur des étudiantes,
après avoir écarté les hommes
de sa trajectoire. L'an dernier,
au Canada, 173 femmes ont été
tuées parce qu'elles étaient
des femmes, une hause e e 26 %
depuis le début de la pandémie.
- On pense aussi à ces femmes
assassinées à Winnipeg qu'on a
découvertes la semaine derniè
Ça continue. Ça continue. Il va
falloir qu'on continue d'agir.
- À i i il y a encore
des femmes, en 2022, qui sont
violentées, parfois assassinées
par leur mari. Il reste du
travail à faire. On a tous
une responsabilité, un devoir
de vigilance.
- Il y a beaucoup de travail à
faire de ce côté-là, on le voit,
surtout le côté prévention pour
pas que justement on réagisse à
chaque fois puis on a pas
prévenu. Puis oui.
- J'ajouterais aussi la
prévention du côté des hommes.
Pourquoi ils font ça? On a beau
dire on ne comprend pas c'est
incompréhensible, peut-être
qu'il faudrait creuser là aussi.
On veut des solutions, mais
pourquoi?
- En attendant de comprendre la
souffrance et la violence
certains hommes...
- Je pense qu'elle va accomplir
de grandes choses et je suis
vraiment fière di.
- Ces ingénieures mère et fille
espère donner l'exemple qu'il
est possible de réaliser ses
rêves, même dans l'adveé.é.é.
Ici Sophie Langlois,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
♪ ♪